i have a cousin
who believes that men have periods and
believes that your videos are
transphobic
please still man the argument for this
and give scientific argument against
steel man the argument that we're
transphobic um well
they stand around the argument that men
have periods
so you know we we have been consistent
and clear that we do not think that
trans is a fiction
we we know trans people we count trans
people among our friends
and um we understand that
um while sex is
uh a a binary effectively a binary going
back to the
anise anisogamy of two very different
gamete types
that in our lineage is 500 million years
old at least uninterrupted
that the manifestation of individual
bodies in regard to what sex they are
are more complex and um therefore some
can be somewhat messier and that there
can be a disconnect between
say your actual sex your actual sex
which is to say you know the gametes
that you produce and your chromosomal
sex which in mammals and birds
um is um is determining what sex you are
and your anatomical and physiological
sex like the you know the primary and
secondary sex characteristics that
um are revealed on your body and
um and also endocrinologically
and then also the sex of your brain and
this is where things get more and more
fuzzy
you know male and female brains are on
average different in some regards i
can't remember which way it goes but
one i should look it up but one one sex
of brain tends to have more white matter
and one sex of brain tends to have more
gray matter for instance
um so you know there are average
differences with yes ton of overlap
between them
but it is it is quite possible given the
complexity and length of development
for signals to get mixed
and for someone to be an actual male for
instance with the brain that feels so
female that it is um irreconcilable for
them to live
as a male and so basically for the for
their
their feeling of their own sex in their
brain
to be not the sex that they are and
therefore to live
their best live lives to live their best
life
um to live as the sex that they are not
and therefore to be
um you know trans
to be to be nice to be respectful i
am fine calling a person i guess i've
used the wrong example but someone who
is actually female
who thinks that who really feels in
their brain that they need to live as a
man
that that trans man will continue
to have periods probably um
frankly if they're continuing to have
periods they probably aren't fully
transitioned because
um once you're on testosterone you
probably are not continuing to have
periods although
you know i don't know enough about the
various endocrinological
uh things to know that for sure um i
would not
call such a person a man they're not a
man they're a trans man
and that is a sign of respect and i'll
be happy to use he him pronouns with
such a person
but at base that person is a biological
female
because biological females are the
people who have periods
not men all right so
i agree with what you said interact very
carefully um i think we can say it
very simply great let's do it okay so
what i would say is trans is a real
phenomenon it is an ancient phenomenon
it is one
that we see in many different cultures
there are uh
allowances for such things and the
expectation that they will happen
sorry so i want you to i'm going to have
you go back and do this briefly again
but let me just
interrupt right there and say we in fact
know that trans is not just
real and ancient but is has many
different causes it's actually multiple
things so for instance
um there's a small population and i
think it is haiti
with what is now understood to be a very
real genetic variant
that produces transness such that the
rate of trans people in this one village
in haiti is sky high compared to you
know every place else where it's a tiny
fraction of one percent
so i think that genetic variant is
unknown in the rest of the world for
instance but so you know in this
particular part of haiti
trans is understood to be caused by a
particular genetic
unknown and no reason to believe it
exists right in other words
it's not typically caused by genes as
far as we know
um okay so by some genetic variant start
again with your brief okay explanation
trans
is ancient natural and there
are allowances for it in many cultures
as a result
when a person is trans
they arrive there by self-designation
by reporting features of their
personality that would tell us that
their
mind feels more female even though their
body is male
and in such a case the right thing to do
is to treat them as a man
for some intents and purposes and that's
the point it's not all intents and
purposes that's why we are fighting over
the term
man right what intents and purposes well
let's just say
loosely social insofar as it doesn't
cause a bigger problem somewhere else
they're not um a man from the point of
view
of a karyotype from the point of view
of their doctor right they are
a man from the perspective of
social interaction and uh our treatment
and then we run into
again places where we can't be so simple
about it when we get
to um sexed bathrooms
sports prison other things where
we actually have to make a call and the
answer is not simple right
so anyway this is for um
survivors of domestic violence sure like
there there is a just like there's a
reason
for um non-symmetrical protections for
women
under the law there is a reason for
women to have spaces
which men cannot enter and
this is an obvious potential way to game
that
and uh we know that even though the vast
majority of people
who are actually trans would never be
doing that that it has happened
right so the simple version the steel
man version is
trans is natural that means that there
are
people who are born female who
transition to male who
may continue to have periods and they
should be treated as men
where practical right but not everything
that's where um we
part ways with the idea that men can
have periods because that's absurd
period
is a a biological
phenomenon there's a reason that it
strikes the mind is inconsistent to hear
that and the mind is not incorrect to
register that inconsistency
so yeah no i mean how do we know that we
are not
transphobic because we've just told you
a
that we've had many trans students that
we
get on well with them that we regard
trans as a natural and ancient
phenomenon that cultures
have incorporated for uh well
thousands of years and how could we
possibly be transphobic if that's what
we're saying that doesn't mean we're not
wrong about stuff but
it's in the idea that we are somehow
hostile to transness is
no i think that's being too generous um
a transphobia
is a term that doesn't mean what it
seems to me
actual transphobia which i haven't
exactly run into
would be it's not real at all there is
there is
there is no there is
no way to be thinking about anyone being
trans
um uh i don't i don't even know what it
would sound like honestly so i'm not
i'm not even sure i think that the word
has
any meaning honestly outside of the
trans rights activists
who use it as a weapon it's used as a
bludgeon um
to and so almost anyone who is wielding
the term transphobia at this point i
would say no
you are reality phobic i'm not
transphobic you are reality phobic
uh let us let us lay out for you what is
actually true
and where the points are that we could
reasonably disagree
and um if if you really believe
that a period which is the result of
a failed fertilization of an egg
event which is as female as
fundamentally
female a process as can possibly be is
something that could be happening in a
male body
then you need a better education we
don't need to
admit that we're transphobic you need to
admit that you're reality phobic
[Music]
you